et avec nous on pour en parler le
général françois chauveau six experts en
géostratégie
bonsoir général merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés bakary traoré journaliste
spécialiste du mali et du sahel bonsoir
à vous aussi merci d'être là vous êtes
bakary traoré en direct de bamako dont
visite surprise dans des manuels macro
lundi prochain dans le pays c'est une
visite nécessaire général chauve ans y
est alors que les relations entre paris
et bamako sont tendues il y à des mises
au point à faire
oui sans aucun doute y ait des mises au
point fr je pense qu'aujourd'hui de
toute façon la france a décidé de
resserrer son dispositif c'est une ce
n'est pas une nouvelle ça fait plusieurs
mois que ça a été évoqué il ya deux
raisons à ça la première est
effectivement il ya des tensions avec le
gouvernement malien sans aucun doute
ensuite vous avez évoqué dans votre
reportage le groupe wagner je crois que
le président mac ont été très clairs sur
la question il peut pas y avoir
cohabitation avec le groupe d'acteurs et
puis maintenant il faut reconnaître le
gouvernement malien a toute sa
responsabilité
pour gérer la crise son territoire il
est souverain c'est à lui de faire ses
choix
justement qui va demander aux autorités
clairement malienne de se positionner
sur la présence de ce groupe
paramilitaire russe wagner selon nos
confrères de rfi il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui l'union européenne a
suspendu temporairement sa mission de
formation des forces armées
centrafricaines ont raison selon de ce
contrôle exercé selon par wagner c'est
vraiment la ligne rouge
bakary traoré comme le disait d'ailleurs
il ya quelques semaines jean yves le
drian
oui
selon le jeune yves le drian bien sûr
que c'est une ligne rouge cette
coopération éventuelle dans le futur
avec avec la société privée l'usso
wagner mais d'écouter du gouvernement de
l'état malien il est toujours question
petit problème de liaison avec bakary
traoré qu'on a récupéré ou pas non voilà
n'ont pas pas encore manifestement
effectivement général chavancy il y aura
cette mise au point nécessaire jean yves
le drian mais la vie d'il ya quelques
semaines ce n'est pas compatible avec la
mission des des européens clairement il
va falloir pour les autorités maliennes
choisir entre ces deux options
à vous tout à fait sans aucun doute la
ligne rouge pour nous elle est très
claire il peut pas y avoir cohabitation
le groupe wagner n'a quand même pas une
très grande
une réputation très positive ne
l'oublions pas quand même il est accusé
d'un certain nombre de méfaits dans
d'autres pays dont la centrafrique et
donc on peut pas se retrouver dans un
contexte comme le mali avec une force
privé de mercenaires avec une force à
régaliennes comme celle de la france qui
vient aider le mali il faut faire un
choix sans aucun doute alors on va
écouter le premier ministre malien qui
avait justement fin septembre critiqué
la france en devant l'onu après la
décision de paris de retirer ses forces
de l'opération barkan sont proposés
d'écouter
le mali regrettes que le principe de
consultation et de concertation qui doit
être la règle entre partenaires
privilégiés n'est pas été observé en
amant de la décision du gouvernement
fera ce la nouvelle situation née de la
fin de barkan place à le mali devant le
fait accompli et l'exposent à 1,7 à une
espèce d'abandon en plein vol nous
conduit à explorer les voies et moyens
pour mieux assurer la sécurité de
manière autonome avec d'autres
partenaires premier ministre malien qui
on le voit se justifie sur ses autres
voix dit-il pour mieux assurer la
sécurité il parle d'abandon
justement sur quels
cas là c'est le sentiment vous avez
aussi et bakary traoré ce qu'on peut
réellement parler aux gens d'abandon
tout cas c'est ce que ressentent de
nombreux maliens oui tout à fait alors
je sais pas si vous me laissez on vous
entend
on vous entend bakary traoré
voilà décidément effectivement mais
justement je vous propose d'aller à
défaut d'entendre la réponse de bakary
traoré d'entendre la voix de certains
maliens interrogé dans dans les rues de
bamako aujourd'hui certains évidemment
se disent inquiets mais surtout déçu par
ce départ
en huit ans de présence au mali l'armée
française n'a rien foutu il faut le dire
je dirais une décennie de perte pour la
nation malienne une décennie comme toi
ont perdu comme ça
c'est un bilan catastrophique si nantes
car l'armée française venait vous avez
vu l'accusé à la queue des maliens
partout un peu partout à bamako à
tombouctou un peu partout de la même
façon si l'armée française décide des
partis ou des séries organisées ou du
moins de quitter un pays vers un point b
la population devait ressentir encore
pour les féliciter mais est-ce que vous
avez vu ça non on est déçu quand la
france dit qu'ils donnent les balles la
base peut aller de l'autre côté de moi
je vois que ce sont des des choses pour
pouvoir écouter conquérir le pouvoir
malien c'est archi faux achim va pas se
laisser faire et le peuple malien si
c'est pas un crime c'est le peuple
malien va pas se laisser faire un
général françois show lanciers ça vous
étonne cette réaction aujourd'hui
de certains habitants malien c'est une
forme d'ingratitude selon vous
tout simplement voilà de la déception
légitime
il ya une déception des maliens mais je
crois que la première question que les
maliens que nous venons d'entendre
devrait se poser est la suivante est-ce
que l'armée malienne a fait tout le
travail en huit ans qu'on attendait de
l'armée de son pays aujourd'hui les
résultats de l'armée malienne commence
un petit peu à s'améliorer grâce à
l'aide des français car ce n'est pas des
français qui doivent se battre pour les
maliens mais les maliens qui doivent se
battre pour les maliens et qu'on les
reportages des interviews à diffuser la
montre bien qu'ils aient une totale
incompréhension
nous avons des citoyens magnin qui
attendent qu'un état étranger la france
viennent faire le travail qui devrait
faire eux mêmes donc je trouve c'est
assez injuste maintenant on peut
comprendre que le sentiment d'insécurité
puisse exister mais il faut pas mettre
ça sur le dos de l'armée française
l'armée française a eu de très bons
résultats en éliminant les chefs
djihadistes c'est la première mission
nous avons ce n'est pas de restaurer la
sécurité qui est de la responsabilité de
l'état malien qui est totalement
responsable de cette situation et c'est
très facile aujourd'hui d'accuser la
france de ne pas avoir fait le travail
la france paye les opérations elles
payent de la vie ses soldats et elle le
fait depuis huit ans sans rien demander
en échange effectivement il y a un peu
d'ingratitude
justement voici
les français ont perdu la vie au mali
pour quel résultat un abandon point
d'interrogation il était peut-être le
temps de partir c'est vrai que je parle
sur votre contrôle 53 morts de soldats
français au mali tout ça pour ça soir et
on tenté de dire aujourd'hui c'est non
pas du tout je n'oublions pas quand même
que nous avons une armée professionnelle
une armée de soldats qui répondent aux
besoins de notre chef des armées et que
notre métier c'est de faire la guerre
donc nous ne la faisons il y à des
pertes ce la risle c'est malheureux mais
il n'y a pas de guerre sans perte je
crois que se focaliser sur le nombre de
soldats français tués en opération en
huit ans n'a pas beaucoup de sens en
géopolitique
il a un sens au point de vue humain mais
pas au point de vue géopolitique
maintenant il est certain mais comme
dans tout guère de ce type c'est une
guerre de contre-insurrection des
groupes terroristes qui sont diluées
dans le paysage sur dix fois la taille
de la france on ne peut pas vaincre
c'est émouvant on ne peut que les
réduire à l'impuissance autant que
possible la solution sera politique
d'ailleurs le président macron l'a dit
il faut une situation politique encore
faut-il que ça ce qui est ce dialogue
entre le gouvernement malien et s'ébroue
à condition qu'ils abandonnent leurs
actions terroristes or ce n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui ce sont des assassins
sous un motif politique ne l'oublions
pas général françois chavance et
désormais c'est la jeune force
européenne takouba qui va assurer la
transition notamment dans dans la zone
des trois frontières on descend
peut-être davantage le nord du pays on
le voit les habitants sont inquiets de
cette résurgence de de terrorisme parce
qu'ils ont raison de l'être
tout à fait c'est une zone qui était
privilégiée par les groupes terroristes
islamistes ne l'oublions pas et ils y
avaient leurs bases donc en plus c'est
une zone très facile pour ces mouvements
dans la mesure où c'est un ya trois
frontières vous avez le niger le burkina
et le mali donc d une zone sont à lire
difficile à contrôler et je dirais que
politiquement donc l'effort est porté
depuis plusieurs mois sinon plusieurs
années sur ce triangle pour justement
rassurer les populations et bien sûr
détruire l'ennemi donc oui les les
habitants ont besoin de cette aide et
c'est ce que nous procurons aujourd'hui
les forces françaises ne se retire pas
du mali à date d'aujourd'hui elle se
réorganise avec moins d'effectifs
peut-être et elles concentrent leurs
efforts sur l'ennemi dans une mission de
destruction qui est un peu différente
est à kouba va le permettre puis ce sont
des forces spéciales dont de plusieurs
pays européens environ 900 hommes je
crois donc effectivement ça va être
plutôt efficace pour la chasse aux
terroristes
c'est beaucoup général françois
champvent 6 merci à bakary traoré
malheureusement cette saison n'a pas
permis de dégager culte et 2 le face à
face que mon souhait qui ont fermé enfin
en tout cas on a eu des clés de lecture
merci à vous d'avoir été en direct avec
nous ce soir